2022 will see the conclusions of the
conference on the future of europe
citizens civil society and stakeholders
will present their ideas for change
parliament and the other eu institutions
have promised in turn to follow up on
them
parliament is set to vote for its
president in january elected every two
and a half years the president chairs
plenary sittings and represents
parliament in eu institutions and the
wider world
parliament has long pushed for more
ambitious climate targets in 2022 meps
will debate the fit for 55 package which
aims for a 55 emissions reduction by
2030.
it's part of the eu's plan to reach net
zero emissions and safeguard
biodiversity
work will continue on a pact on
migration and asylum parliament will
examine ways of making the system fairer
and more effective ensuring both better
screening of new arrivals and protection
for those in need
digital services are a vital part of
people's lives and of europe's economy
but the internet and social media are
also home to hate speech disinformation
and counterfeit goods
meps will look at legislation to create
a safe online environment that protects
both users and service providers
parliaments will celebrate european
cinema with the 2022 lux audience award
viewers together with meps will vote for
their favorite film and the winner will
be announced in parliament in june
parliament is due to vote on special
committee recommendations on some of the
eu's biggest challenges
they include dealing with foreign
interference in european democracies
building a value-based framework for ai
and fostering joint action in the fight
against cancer
[Music]
you